I want to play this a little bit of this
report for you there's like a hateful
person beside it and another one's
inside and it has big guys are looking
at us and it's still there
okay where is this on your property
uh in my backyard
I swear to God this is not a joke this
is actually weird
so there's two people or two
or Two Jacks that are in your backyard
correct and they're very large they're
like Facebook nice
they look like they look like I know
these Diamond operators they hear a lot
of crazy stuff I like how casual she's
so casual about it this guy's like yeah
I'm looking at space aliens they're 10
feet tall they have big eyes space space
heads that crash landed in my in my
backyard and she says oh okay so and
where are they where are these 10 foot
creatures oh they're standing right
there okay